Dann sind die Kinder lieber tot, als dass
die Behörde am Schluss Recht behält,
und die Kinder wieder zurückkämen.
Frank Urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
Gerichtspsychiater der Schweiz.
Wenn die Medien Fragen haben, liefert er Antworten.
Wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten Fälle mit denen er als
Gutachter zu tun hatte.
Am Neujahrstag 2015 tötete die damals 27-jährige Mutter ihre beiden Kinder,
zwei und fünf Jahre alt.
Vorausgegangen war,
dass die Kinder von der KESB
in einem Heim platziert wurden.
Die Täterin beging dann acht Monate später in Untersuchungshaft Selbstmord.
Die KESB erlaubt, dass die Kinder über die Feiertage bei der Mutter in Flaach sein dürfen.
Anschliessend sollen sie vorübergehend
zurück ins Heim.
Die Frau will das mit einer Beschwerde
verhindern, als sie erfährt, dass diese
Beschwerde abgewiesen wurde,
tötet sie ihre Kinder.
Letztlich war das Motiv,
dass es einen Machtkampf gab zwischen
der Behörde, die die Kinder ins Heim
gebracht hatte und der Mutter, die das
auf gar keinen Fall akzeptieren wollte.
Man könnte etwas verkürzt sagen, dass die Mutter aufgrund des Machtkampfes,
am Schluss sogar bereit war, dann bis zur letzten Konsequenz zu gehen,
und zu sagen, dann sind die Kinder lieber
tot, als dass die Behörde am Schluss
Recht behält und die Kinder wieder
zurückkämen.
Der KESB wird unter anderem vorgeworfen,
sie hätte realisieren müssen,
was passieren könnte, wenn sie die Frau
dermassen in die Enge treibe.
Wenn man alles gewusst hätte, zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt,
dann hätte man es verhindern können,
Aber man muss fairerweise sagen,
diese Problematik war für die Behörde
unmöglich zu erkennen.
Die Behörden nahmen Auffälligkeiten wahr,
die nahmen wahr, dass da bestimmte Sachen, die gesagt wurden, nicht stimmten.
Für die stellten sich Fragen.
Es war aber wie eine verschlossene Tür,
bei der die Behörden nicht wussten,
was hinter der Tür steckt.
Dass dies hinter der Tür lauerte,
wussten sie nicht,
konnten sie nicht wissen.
Es ist ja auch etwas,
dass in dieser Form extrem selten ist.
Daher würde ich insgesamt sagen, theoretisch hätte man das wissen können,
oder hätte das Risiko zumindest
ahnen können.
Praktisch hatte die Behörde keine Möglichkeit,
weil die Behörde die Informationen
dafür gar nicht hatte.
Die Mutter der getöteten Kinder hat sich
bereits das Leben genommen,
als Urbaniok das Gutachten über sie schreibt.
Ich habe selbst mit der Täterin nicht geredet,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass das ein reines Aktengutachten war.
Denn wir machen Gutachten
sehr oft im Team,
das dann unterschiedliche
Phasen im Gutachten-Prozess begleitet.
Zum Beispiel werden von Mitarbeitern bestimmte Sachen schon gemacht.
In diesem Fall lagen bereits sehr ausführliche
Gespräche und Explorationen vor.
Sie wurden durch eine enge Mitarbeiterin
von mir geführt, und ich war absolut im
Bilde was dort gesprochen wurde,
was dort der Sachstand war,
weil wir diese Explorationen immer
vor- und nachbesprochen,
und sofort die weitere Strategie
festgelegt haben.
Es nicht mehr
dazugekommen, dass ich
abschliessend mit der Täterin
sprechen konnte und dann zum Beispiel
auf einige Widersprüche noch mal selber
hinweisen konnte.
Aber es lag damals eine
ausserordentlich gute
Informationsgrundlage vor.
Urbanioks Gutachten soll erklären,
wieso die beiden Kinder am 1. Januar 2015
im Haus ihrer Mutter sterben müssen.
Es hat viel mit grundlegenden Persönlichkeitseigenschaften
der Täterin zu tun.
Ein sehr wichtiger ist der
«instabile Realitätsbezug».
Das bedeutet, dass Menschen,
die gefühlte Realität über
die tatsächliche Realität setzen.
Sie können beliebig Realitäten
und Glaubenssätze austauschen
und leben in gewisser Weise
in einer Scheinwelt,
in der sie auch beliebig viele
Möglichkeiten haben,
das eine zu denken oder für richtig zu halten.
Es gibt eine Fülle von Beispielen,
die in die Richtung gehen, dass die Täterin
Dinge erzählt hat, die einfach nicht
stimmten und die aber aus dem Gefühl
heraus, ganz überzeugend vertreten wurden.
Sie erzählte dann der Behörde, dass sie
mit dem Privatjet angeflogen sei.
Sie zusammen mit ihrem damaligen Partner,
das war so ein Mietnomadentum,
dass man Wohnungen dort bewohnte und dann aber wieder auszog ohne Miete zu zahlen.
Dass man als Käufer auftrat von grossen Immobilien, ohne das Geld zu haben.
Es war seit langer Zeit ein Leben
an der Grenze der Realität.
Oder man könnte auch sagen:
Viel mehr Schein als Sein.
Für die Täterin selber war es aber nie ein Problem.
Dinge, die für sie emotional stimmig waren,
die sich gut anfühlten, als die
Realität anzusehen.
Als die Realität zu verkaufen.
Man kann generell sagen bei Menschen
mit einem instabilen Realitätsbezug ist
die Wirklichkeit beliebig austauschbar.
Man muss keine Grenze
überspringen, um etwas Falsches,
Wahrheitswidriges zu vertreten oder zu
glauben.
Weil innerlich ist es immer so,
wenn es vom Gefühl stimmt,
dann ist damit die Geschichte legitim.
Anfang 2016 informiert die Zürcher Justizdirektion
über die Ergebnisse von zwei Gutachten
zum Fall Flaach.
Eines davon ist von Urbaniok.
Es gab Verfahrenschritte,
die waren optimal und beispielhaft.
Bei anderen harzte es.
Dort konnten die Angehörigen
schlecht nachvollziehen,
was jetzt wirklich passiert, wieso eine
Behörde diese Schritte macht,
was der Rechtskontext ist, und auch wie sie sich dagegen wehren könnten.
Da müssen Verbesserungen passieren.
Bei den Grosseltern hätte ein eingerichtetes Zimmer auf die Kinder gewartet.
Aber die KESB bevorzugte eine Lösung in einem Kinderheim.
Für die Grosseltern ist es unverständlich.
Sie kennen alles hier, sind zuhause.
Sie sind hier schon in die Spielgruppe gegangen,
kennen den Spielplatz.
Da draussen sind sie Velo gefahren.
Hier sind sie zuhause.
Hier hätten sie Liebe und Zuneigung gehabt.
In dieser Zeit, in der die Eltern im Gefängnis gewesen wären oder was auch immer.
Die Rolle der Grosseltern ist ein weiterer
tragischer Aspekt dieses ganzen Falles.
Die Grosseltern kannten ja ihre Tochter,
sie kannten die Problematik.
Sie beobachteten von aussen,
dass sich das Rad immer schneller drehte.
Dass es eine Welt war,
die auf Schein aufgebaut war.
Sie machten sich Sorgen um die Kinder.
Sie sahen sich mehr in
der Rolle von Reserve-Eltern,
um da eine gewisse Stabilität zu gewährleisten.
Jetzt platzte das System durch die Inhaftierung
wegen Betrugshandlungen.
Jetzt sahen die Grosseltern
den Zeitpunkt gekommen,
wo sie fast sagten,
wenigstens kommt das jetzt mal zum Stillstand,
wenigstens kann man das jetzt
in geordnete Bahnen lenken.
Sie waren bereit,
die Kinder jetzt zu übernehmen.
Aus ihrer Sicht absolut
ehrenwert und verständlich.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das
auch eine gute Lösung gewesen.
Jetzt verstehe ich aber auch die Behörde,
die Kinder- und Erwachsenenschutzbehörde,
für die wirkt es komisch, dass plötzlich von einem Moment zum anderen,
in Form der Grosseltern
Reserve-Eltern zur Verfügung stehen.
Die stellen sich die Frage,
wenn jetzt die Grosseltern die Kinder übernehmen,
kann man die Mutter später
in ihrer Mutterrolle noch einmal installieren?
Sie waren den Grosseltern
gegenüber etwas reserviert .
Die Grosseltern konnten das gar nicht verstehen.
Weil sie kannten die Situation und sagten,
aber das ist doch jetzt genau der Zeitpunkt,
wo wir in die Bresche springen müssten.
So schaukelte sich das gegenseitig mit einem gewissen Misstrauen hoch.
Aus der subjektiven Sicht der beiden
durchaus verständlich.
Aber natürlich im Ergebnis absolut tragisch.
Weil es kam dann deswegen gerade nicht dazu,
dass man den Grosseltern
die Kinder zur Obhut übergab.
Mit den entsprechenden Folgen.
Der Fall löste eine nationale Debatte über die KESB aus, die bis heute andauert.